تخيل انك تقف تحت شمس حارقه حرارتها تصل
الى الخمسين درجه مئويه لكن الارض من تحتك
بارده تماما وكان الشمس لم تمسها هذا
بالضبط ما ستشعر به في الحرم المكي عند
مشيك على ارضيته الرخاميه فما سر بروده
ارضيه المسجد الحرام السر ليس في اجهزه
تبريد تحت الارض ولا مراوح ولا تقنيات
متطوره الرئاسه العامه لشؤون المسجد
الحرام والمسجد النبوي اوضحت ان سر في
بروده الارضيات يعود الى نوعيه الرخام
المستخدم في الحرم المكي الشريف ذلك نوع
من الرخام يتم استيراده خصوصا من جزيره
تاسوس في اليونان ويسمى على اسم الجزيره
رخامه تاسوس ويصل سمكه في الحرم الى خمسه
سنتيمترات وهذه النوعيه منه تعمل على عكس
الضوء والحراره حيث انه يمتص رطوبه عبر
مسامى دقيقه خلال الليل وفي النهار يقوم
باخراج ممتصه في الليله ما يجعله دائما
البروده حتى في درجات الحراره العاليه